hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast growing together lessons
learned from the characterization of the
pediatric microbiome presented by Emily
dr. Emily Hollister we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
roche diagnostics as a global leader in
health care roche diagnostics offers a
broad portfolio of tools that help
healthcare providers in early detection
prevention diagnosis and treatment of
diseases in molecular diagnostics the
company is driven by a vision of working
with laboratories like yours to improve
medical value you offer in microbiology
infectious diseases oncology and
genomics Roche Diagnostics continues to
meet unmet needs through its investment
in research innovation and scientific
excellence with the goal of supporting
your important role in improving
patients lives to learn more about roche
diagnostics please visit us diagnostics
Roche com I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem thank you now I'd like
to introduce dr. Emily Hollister dr.
Hollister is a microbial ecologist and
bioinformatics 'used she's interested in
quantifying and characterizing microbial
communities
a wide variety of environments including
the human body utilizing high-throughput
next-generation DNA and RNA sequence
approaches her research seeks to improve
our understanding of microbial
communities their distribution across
time and space the ways in which they
function and their influence of rocdur
scales dr. Hollister currently serves as
the director of microbial ecology and
bioinformatics for the Texas Children's
microbiome Center please join me in
welcoming dr. Hollister I will now turn
the presentation over to her thank you
Judy before I get started I'd like to
disclose that this is a sponsored talk
by roche and with that will launch into
my presentation and which as Jay
mentioned is entitled growing together
lessons learned from the
characterization of the pediatric
microbiome today I plan to discuss on
with you the importance of the pediatric
microbiome the gut microbiome and its
relationship with human development and
the aging process and some other
application of microbiome science and
pediatrics over the course of the last
10 years micro bio related studies have
gained tremendous foothold in the
literature and popular press this has
been fooled by advances and sequencing
technology and a growing awareness of
them are microbial world as such the
science has begun to describe micro
biomes and places we never thought to
look or try to look before and it
doesn't take much work beyond that the
pages of cell science or nature or or
honestly many journals beyond the scope
to to find that there's no and the
variety of microbiome studies being
conducted from describing the structure
and function of a healthy human
microbiome in a context of the human my
club here in microbiome project
sponsored by the National
institutes of health here in the United
States to looking at the gut microbiome
across age and biogeography to looking
at the microbiome in a variety of other
locations and and and places new
microbiome findings are being relate or
reported on a daily basis and what are
we learning from all this it's been
about 10 years since the first articles
describing next-gen sequencing were
published in about eight years since
launch of the human microbiome project
and really what we've learned from this
to date it has been in part in large
part of natural history a large amount
of time and effort has gone into
documenting what occurs when and where
and it's right to help helping us define
or at least begin to define healthy and
normal for a variety of community types
very interestingly and certainly of
importance to my own field defining or
linking changes in microbiome to states
of disease and health and as we think
toward the future rethinking
conventional approaches to management
therapy diagnostics and treatment we
know the human gut microbiome is
intimately linked to our developmental
continuum and this conceptual diagram
from a Nature Reviews microbiology
manuscript published about four years
ago provides a conceptual outline of
these microbiome changes over the course
of one's life and the various factors
that influence microbiome structure and
function over time as we move through
various life stages a variety of factors
contribute to shaping our microbial
communities this may be factors such as
host genetics delivery mode and diet in
early life the developing immune system
illness nutrition antibiotic exposure
during childhood
and a variety of other things as we move
through our life stages exposure to
different people compound substances
diets stressors a variety of things
interact with our own bodies and our
microbiomes to shape their interaction
with one another although there are
exceptions the variety the most of
microbiome studies to date have focused
primarily on infants or adults and would
would studies like human microbiome
project and med hit providing large
amounts of information regarding the
Western healthy Western adult microbiome
also providing some insights into IBD
the pediatric microbiome however
especially in children and teens is less
well characterized being at a Children's
Hospital this is that a main source of
work and focus for us in the last couple
of years but why is the pediatric
microbiomes so important and well after
a lot of research suggests and a lot of
thinking suggests that on the pediatric
microbiome has the potential to shape
influence the shape of things to come we
realize that there's or there is a
growing awareness in the community or
the importance of the microbiome during
pediatric development and its potential
to influence health outcomes later in
life and evidence for this is mounting
it appears and certainly there certainly
appears to be a link between the gut
microbiome and autoimmune status and
work from a couple of different
publications over the last couple of
years have demonstrated this either from
the perspective of a priming the immune
system early in life or signaling immune
chain autoimmune changes the onset of
type 1 diabetes for example
we also know that the pediatric window
and the gut microbiome are linked to
cognitive development and behavior and
there's some some beautiful work done in
animal models suggesting that cognitive
and development and behavior are excuse
me very closely linked to the microbiome
work in germ-free animals highlighted
here on the left has demonstrated that
germ-free animals are those lacking an
intact microbiome showed decrease
inhibition and that there's a specific
window in which this can be corrected
now decrease inhibition is is a hallmark
of abnormal behavior in mice and and so
mice lacking and intact microbiome
behave differently from those who are
raised under conventional conditions why
cries recent work publishing brain
behavior in DNA suggests that alteration
of the microbiome with chronic
antibiotic exposure can also lead to
altered behavior and diminished
cognitive ability in young mice in both
cases here the lighter color figure or
the lighter color in each video
represents a control control mice and
the darker color represents microbiome
depleted or altered ie germ-free or
antibiotic treated mice so clearly
there's a strong link between the
microbio or at least evidence is
suggesting strong links between the gut
microbiome and our own development and
behavior along this gut brain access we
know the camera models also suggest that
early life antibiotic exposure and
modulation of the microbiome can also
lead to increase risk for obesity and
adiposity work out of Marty Blazers lab
in New York and work performed by Lori
Hawks and others suggest that chronic
early life antibiotic exposure can lead
to a disrupted microbio
and the potential for increased
adiposity so as we think about this the
human microbiome and the developmental
continuum we're seeing mounting evidence
from both human studies and animal
models suggesting the importance of the
microbiome during early life I'd like to
invite you to take a step back though
and consider what else we know about the
microbiome and are sort of earliest
stages so we've learned over the last
several years that were not necessarily
sterile at birth this has been a
long-held assumption that a newborn or
and the fetus is is more or less
protected from microbial exposure until
birth however a variety of studies have
demonstrated that meconium were
basically the first fecal material
actually is fully populated with
microbes at the time of birth what I'm
showing you is a microbial community
characterization from meconium performed
or published in 2013 where each one of
these pairs of bars represents a single
infant sampled at different points in
meconium either an internal sample or an
external sample and what we see is that
regardless of sampling point and there
are detectable microbes and there are a
variety of microbial configurations even
from the first day of life so we know
that we're not sterile at birth we've
also learned that the placenta is not
sterile either this is work that was
performed by sheer Sierra's group at
Baylor College of Medicine and published
last year in Science Translational
Medicine what their group found was that
placental tissues Harbor detectable
bacterial DNA and that this but the
composition of these placental microbial
communities is actually quite different
from that of the vagina in other body
sites that have been previously
characterized by groups working with
human microbiome project
interestingly this community shares
shares a high degree of similarity or at
least when compared to other body sites
shares the greatest degree of similarity
with those from rural communities
providing extra evidence to suggest the
strong link between oral health and and
birth outcomes we've also recently
learned that the universe isn't sterile
either this is data but that appeared
recently in a pure Journal preprints
article evaluating bacterial community
composition and endometrial samples from
nineteen non-pregnant women and very
interestingly we find taxa that are very
commonly associated with the gut
bacteroides irina solvents as well as as
tax that are commonly found in the
vaginal tract the lactobacillus type
species we've also known however i've
learned that delivery mode may influence
your microbiome and conflicting evidence
suggests that once early microbiome can
be further shaped or shaped beyond
what's initially seated by mode of
delivery Gloria domingos bellos group
published this paper in early 2010's
highly cited and this group found that
infants delivered by caesarean section
Harbor microbiome that resembles that a
human skin while those who develop
delivered by a vaginal delivered via
vaginal a mode of birth tend to
represent mom's vagina however others
who've attempted to replicate the study
have found that motive birth doesn't
really matter quite so much as as
previously thought regardless of your
mode of birth third mode of delivery the
human gut microbiome changes rapidly
into
matically over the first few years of
life and is influenced by a number of
factors including diet illness
antibiotic exposure this is from a study
published out of Ruth lays group this
Tony paper from 2011 when they tracked a
single infant over the course of roughly
two and a half to three years and from
birth through early childhood through
exposure table foods antibiotics
socialization and other other features
of this child's early life we can see
that the gut microbiome changes over
time more interestingly or as as
interestingly on this this progression
has often been described as one that's
very chaotic but in contrast what we see
is a sunny progression of an increase in
phylogenetic diversity over time and an
increased or a steady progression of
differentiation over time as this
particular child's microbio matures we
find the best study increasing richness
or the increasing richness is a steady
feature over the first several years of
life this is data published by tanya
watson anko in 2012 and I've also found
that this may actually serve as an index
for maturation when we look at children
who are developing normally versus those
who may be malnourished and falling off
of the regular growth charts we find
that the steady progression tends to be
a consistent feature if one is happy but
if one tends to be falling off of this
track it can to suggest that the
microbiome is surveying is an indicator
of malnutrition and poor development as
we continue to mature the gut microbiome
becomes more adult-like overtime on
suggesting that by the time a child
reaches roughly three to four years of
age
their gut microbiome has reached an
adult like stage and sharing roughly
fifty to sixty percent similarity with
those of adults with Willard children
and adults but as notably the microbiome
continues to change as we age and not
surprisingly really this maturation
doesn't end is the age of three we find
that the microbiome continues to change
over time regardless of where you live
or which culture you belong to and but
even into adulthood one can use micro
bio based markers to distinguish younger
adults from older adults and Centurions
and now this change involves both
composition so the types of bacteria
that are present as well as function
when we compare adults and infants not
surprisingly we find very dramatic
differences in the function and
functional potential of the microbiome
related to things like amino acid
metabolism metabolism and utilization of
vitamins and cofactors if we take that
same type of functional information from
a shotgun meta-genome we found land at
all actually found that one can
reasonably distinguish younger adults
from older adults suggesting that there
is a young adult signature and an older
adult signature that can be picked out
from functional information that got
microbiome taking a couple steps back
down that developmental continuum we
find that even though children can be
distinct or children tend to reach an
adult like stage by the time they're
three or four years old chatting and
adults still differ from one another
quite dramatically with respect to their
community composition and the types of
functional genes
that they carry and this is consistent
across multiple sequencing technologies
what I'm highlighting here is data that
we've recently published out of our
group at Texas Children's and the Texas
Children's microbiome center where we
compared healthy adults and healthy
children with one another these are
adults who were recruited as a part of
the human microbiome project and happen
to be from the Houston area and healthy
children who were also recruited from
Houston Texas utilizing similar
sequencing approaches we characterize
communities using 16s ribosomal RNA gene
sequencing as well as shotgun meta
genomic approaches and what we find is
that regardless the sequencing approach
we find relatively consistent
differences in community composition now
we're not the first to have described
this others have looked a few others
have looked at comparisons of children
and adults using microbial community
composition and not surprisingly when
they look they do find differences
whether they used chaka are on 16s
sequencing or microarray technology we
find that children adults differ from
one another with respect to composition
however our group is among the first to
have taken the next stage to carry this
out and look at functional differences
and what we find is that in combination
with these texts amount of differences
we do see some differences in functional
potential between children and adults
one of these build upon those that have
been described in comparison with
infants and adults for example town yet
to nego at all in their 2012 agent
biogeography paper described specific
differences between the gut microbial
communities of children and adults with
respect to dietary acquisition versus de
novo metabolism of b vitamins including
folate and vitamin b12 very
interestingly what they reported was
that adults tended to have a greater
capacity for b12 metabolism nanded
infants whereas what we find is that
children actually exceed the potential
functional potential for b12 metabolism
then I have a greater impact
tencel for b12 metabolism they're adults
and adults sit in the middle of this
spectrum relative to infants so what we
find is that it appears there is sort of
a peak of potential at in children and
correlating evidence from the literature
suggests that lifetime vitamin b12
actually peaks or blood concentrations
of b12 peak around seven to eight years
of age so it makes sense that
cooperation from the microbiome at this
stage of life would go along with this
and what I'm showing you here on the
left hand side is a portion of the
vitamin b12 synthesis pathway where box
is highlighted in green are our enzymes
for which we see increased relative
abundance of genes in the gut microbiota
and the gut microbiomes I've children
relative to adults those highlighted in
gray are enriched and adults relative to
children simply look at a broader
perspective we see that although not
quite as as pretty as the heat map
produced by yobsn tengo atolls group we
do see if there is a differentiation of
children and adults among with respect
to multiple functional pathways in the
gut microbiome again linked to things
like amino acid metabolism uh excuse me
while I use the pointer amino acid
metabolism vitamin synthesis and a
variety of other types of functions
interestingly too we find that key
pathways to previously described in the
context of inflammation aging and the
development of node bad diseases differ
between children and adults on a large
scale overall receive it children and
adults do generally different from one
another though not exclusively with
respect to overall community composition
and their functional gene pathways but
when we look at key pathways related to
either health promotion or metabolic
disease and inflammation we see key
differences the porphyrin chlorophyll
the travel is a pathway again is that
vitamin b12 oh just highlighted methane
metabolism has also been linked to
improved relative health in the with
respect to the gut microbiome in
contrast things like us functions like
genes involved in the turbot carboxylic
acid cycle of a polysaccharide
biosynthesis and oxidative
phosphorylation suggest increase
potential for inflammation or the
ability to deal with oxidative products
and overall these changes like these
appear to have implications for health
others have previously reported shifts
in microbial composition related to
general health in the elderly for
example community richness or gene
richness in the community or total gene
counts where increased increased gene
counts tended to be indicative a better
overall health whereas lodging-house
tend to be indicative of poorer overall
health as well as increased community
richness over time likewise at lea at
all published in 2013 this hygiene count
low gene cal hygiene count Mojang cal
paradigm where they described
individuals who had hygiene counts being
a better overall health and decreased
risk for adiposity and metabolic disease
relative to those who carry low gene
count I microbiome phenotypes so clearly
the mounting evidence suggests that the
microbiome does influence the shape of
things to come as we consider our
knowledge of the human microbiome and it
did the development developmental
continuum recent it becomes apparent
that recent findings are
defining our understanding of various
life stages for example until recently
it was very much how's that the unborn
child was sterile we know now that's not
the case that while microbial loads may
potentially be very loud are they are
present and we assume beginning to
influence the early stages and the early
foundations of the human microbiome
relationship we're also learning that
once a child reaches roughly three years
of age there's still additional
development that will go on not
surprisingly our bodies continue to
develop over time we it appears with the
microbiome develops along with us
however we had a number of gaps that are
in our knowledge still very little is
known about the teenage microbiome what
happens in that complex crazy roller
coaster ride of puberty and the onset of
adult sex hormones and was still
learning more about the transition a
month or across these stages and into
older age while we do have some great
baseline data there's still a lot left
to be learned learned so in addition to
describing the development of the
healthy human microbiome there's
tremendous interest in applying
microbiome science to the study of
pediatric disease I'm going to take an
opportunity here to highlight some of
the projects that we've had ongoing at
Texas Children's Hospital in Texas
Children's microbiomes that are where we
have a very active research community
who's interested in applying microbiome
science to their own particular sub
specialties and conditions of interest
and so I'd like to tell you a few little
few short stories about some of the work
that we've been doing we have a couple
of collaborators from the Department of
me and eight ology has been very
interested in studying the airway
microbial
and premature infants and the degree to
which the airway microbiome can be used
to predict the development of serious
conditions like bronchopulmonary
dysplasia this work was led by Pablo
woman and what we found is actually
really interesting again going along
with that idea of the child is not
sterile at birth previous studies have
attempted to address their way
microbiome in preterm neonates and the
one previous study that comes to mind
actually was unable to detect bacterial
DNA until two to three days of life
whereas in our study pablos the children
probably recruited where we were able to
get detectable bacterial DNA from birth
and follow these children over time
including the development of
bronchopulmonary dysplasia or those
preterm neonates who are ventilated but
went on to have healthier outcomes and
what we find is that in these preterm
neonates from very early on those who go
on to develop BPD have lower bacterial
richness over tongue at onset and over
time and their community shifts very
rapidly to one that contains taxa that
are potentially problematic so even from
three days of life we see that we may
have a biomarker or a potential signal
of things that are about to change
beyond the respiratory tract we will
also have a variety of GI collaborators
who are interested in characterizing the
microbio with respect to the two
conditions of interest one of these
happens to be the fecal microbiome in
patients of short bowel syndrome this is
work carried out by Zeb Vivek's who was
a fellow here and is now
Connecticut ends of spend some time
characterizing the fecal microbiome and
a handful variety of patients with short
bowel syndrome and trying to figure out
the degree to which symptoms might be
correlated with microbiome composition
largely what we found was that symptoms
were not but that we could very clearly
distinguish the healthy microbiome from
one a short bowel syndrome um other
words that we've been had ongoing has
been looking at dietary interventions
and in particular bridge to vote Ozzy
from MGI division has been interested in
looking at children with your book
irritable bowel syndrome and they degree
to which dietary interventions like the
low fodmap diet may be efficacious and
had an interaction with the microbiome
early work from Bruno suggests that
baseline microbiome composition may be
an indicator of how well particular
children may respond to this dietary
intervention which is fairly harsh a
removal of a large variety of
potentially fermentable carbohydrates
orses and if we can help direct patients
predict which patients may respond
better to the five bucks intervention
before they go on it we could save
families a lot of time trouble and
potential disappointment if the
intervention didn't work we've also been
working very closely with Richard Keller
Meyer and our GI division who's been
doing work with fecal microbiota
transplantation and we have a fecal
microbiota transplantation program in
effect for clostridium difficile
infection and we've had some ongoing
work with an IND approval from the FDA
looking at FMT applications and
ulcerative colitis and what Richard has
been able to show is that FMT in
ulcerative colitis patients does appear
at least a nose with low-grade
inflammation of low-grade disease does
appear to produce transient beneficial
effects that from the time in
them this is a case study of a single
subject from the time of enrollment
through multiple transplants we see that
the microbial community changes over
time becomes much more like the donor
and following the donor here in red and
following removal from the protocol
begins to drift away from the the donor
and Miss health potentially healthier
state so again that transient effect we
look at three different patients what we
find is that over time going from an
untreated state to pre FMT to post FMT
we will get colonic biopsy specimens
mucosal biopsy specimens we see an
improvement in in structure in
epithelial in epithelial structure and
overall tissue health providing new one
setting and so we've been doing a fair
amount of work to try to track my
clinical community response in these
patients to the fmt treatment but also
track host response in terms of clinical
symptoms that also host gene expression
and things along those lines so what we
find with our human microbiome work and
our pediatric work is that the human
microbiome in the pediatric window is
definitely important thing and clearly
an opport provides a number of
opportunities for research we we know
that the microbiome or we're beginning
to appreciate that the microbiome
appears to be seated well before birth
and continues to develop with us as we
move through along the aging continuum
there's actually a really fantastic
paper that was just published in cell
reports it's actually an uncorrupted
immediate did proof at this point from
Clark at all looking at the development
of the GI microbiome with a ginger
savoie and looking at the effects of
aging aging in the microbiome into soft
law particularly with respect to
declines in barrier
function and immune function as the the
drosophila age this is I think I
harbinger of things to come and as we
begin to understand how the microbiome
changes along with us and what the
implications are for health certainly
what the implications are for health and
where there may be potential
opportunities for diagnosis or
intervention or potential correction
modulation as we go clearly growing
evidence suggests that the pediatric
window represents a pediatric period
represents an important window with
respect to host microbiome interaction
via the development of autoimmune
disease predisposition to metabolic
disease or adiposity leader in life or
shaping our cognitive development and
behavior pediatric the pediatric window
appears to be very tightly linked to the
structure and function of the gut
microbiome and is something that we will
certainly be wanting to learn more about
be working more on but it suggests that
this is a very important period in time
for our development and that of our
microbiome and we're learning with a the
pediatric microbiome although it don't
like he's not fully adult the child's
microbiome appears to share many adult
like qualities the differences in
composition composition and function
suggest that additional development is
likely to occur as we begin to fill in
more the blanks along the developmental
continuum this this idea is likely to be
flushed out more and the importance of
it will be flushed out more and as I've
indicated there's so many unanswered
questions with respect to the pediatric
microbiome at our body sites but new
findings continue to challenge long-held
paradigms and for example for the
sterility of the microbiome at Birth as
well
as this idea that by the time one
reaches three years of age were we're
pretty much done developing our
microbiomes so challenging long-held
paradigms informing future diagnostics
they're fencing very nice applications
of this suggesting that we may have some
developmental indices available to us as
fun as a readout from the human
microbiome but beyond that we may also
be able to gather insight into them like
cardinal diseases and polymicrobial
diseases from the microbiome and
certainly shaping interventions if we
can direct therapies more specifically
we may one hoops have more success or a
greater success at treating treating
disease and promoting health so with
that I will give some acknowledgments to
a variety of my collaborators based here
at Texas Children's Hospital and Baylor
College of Medicine particularly those
who are involved in the Texas Children's
microbiome Center including our director
Jim versa lytic roof and luna who
directs our sequencing group shoot IV
garage tour Savage who are associate
directors at a variety of others without
whom the work I've shared today would
not have been possible I've mentioned a
variety of our other collaborators from
unit ology the GI in hepatology group
and we also work very closely with
divinely provides research laboratory at
Baylor College of Medicine the alkek
center for microbiome and meta genomic
research and human genome sequencing
center and finally of course some of the
work that I've described today was
funded by the National Institutes of
Health and iddk and specifically under
the huge specifics uuh three funding
mechanism with that I think we can move
on to questions thank you
thank you dr. Hollister for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A so if you have a question you'd like
to ask dr. Hollister please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button well answers many of
your questions is we have time for let's
get started the first question is can a
pediatric microbiome affect a child in
the most current studies of abd ADH and
defiant disorder that's a great question
and that's a great question there's
certainly ongoing work in our group and
others attempting to address this
question we're at leat well actually I
take that back I'm thinking we're above
autism spectrum disorders but certainly
some of the to my knowledge some of
these may affect or may also file onto
the autism spectrum it's not
unreasonable to suggest that they could
to my knowledge I don't know
specifically if they're ongoing studies
work from animal models does suggest
that our got microbial communities again
as I as I've showed some evidence from
earlier je kans can affect behavior and
and it it certainly may be possible and
the results from the germ-free mouse
models showing lack of inhibition are
intriguing and suggestive and I think
this is probably an opportunity for for
work down the line is it correct to say
that vaccinations can disrupt the
natural process and development of the
human microbiome
this is also a great question and I do
not know the answer I've certainly seen
some some preprint manuscripts that
attempt to address this question though
it's hard to say we certainly know there
are benefits from vaccinations global
benefits community benefits I don't know
I think I'll we've answered that we know
that we have an important bacterial
flora in different organs including our
mouths are the bacteria that we consider
useless or harmful important for the
survival of our own flora and also with
our flora survive would be the same
without them um I think that um yeah
you're the question is absolutely
correct and that we have for bacteria
reside on in and on our bodies at a
variety of sites and i think that
there's still a lot we're learning about
the interactions among bacterial
community members so those that may not
be apparent apparent use and in that
they're not a known beneficial organism
or known pathogen i think there's still
a lot of taxa out there that we're still
just not sure what they do we know that
in some cases there is a very intimate
relationship between between some taxa
and that they were a sort they require
one another for cone metabolism for
survival for co culture conditions if
you will and so i think that there's
still a lot to learn as to how and why
does those particular pet taxa excuse me
the ones that we think are sort of
neutral
what they're doing there and and so I
wouldn't I would suggest that the the
author of this question is probably
correct in that these these particular
taxes that we don't yet understand may
it be important for the survival of
others and the ones that we tend to
value does an external factor such as a
family pet affect a child's microbiome
there is evidence to suggest that the
presence of a family pet can affect the
microbiome I believe that Rob Knights
group published a paper on this not that
long ago and they've been suggestions
from the allergy and immunity literature
that having well literature and even
folklore that having a pet around can
affect a microphone on microbiome and
allergic responses later in life but yes
I believe the answer believe the answers
yes but that I a child's microbiome can
be affected by the presence of a family
pet I ever cry from that but study from
Rob Knights group that family pets and
their owners tended to share more
bacterial taxa in common with one
another then did two separate humans who
did not live together so the close
relationship between humans and their
pets suggests that there is some degree
and maybe more than we realize of
bacterial swapping going back and forth
the vagina has bacteria so how can a
newborn be sterile right that's a great
question and so the Assumption i think
the long-held assumption was that that
it would be an internally sterile
condition that the lungs the GI tract
other body sites I guess internal body
sites would be serial clearly that's not
the case and we're learning that that as
I said the long-held assumption in
medicine and perhaps the very first one
was that so not so much the newborn but
the fetus if you would well in cases
other in cases of a healthy child one
that was not affected for example by a
condition like chorioamnionitis would be
sterile as I said we're learning that's
not the case and and we probably
shouldn't have expected that to be the
case at all we're almost out of time so
this may have to be our last question is
it possible to establish community types
and children are they totally different
to the antero types ABCD in adults I
believe people have looked for and here
are types and sheltering and I know
early on in our group we did we did do
some initial characterization to see if
we could recreate the interior types
described by the European authors that
the meta hit authors and so if they do
appear to exist we do know that that
full gradient of community types if you
consider the sort of bacteroides to
firmicutes gradient its president adults
and present in children and
we believe that whether you consider int
arrow types or enterin gradients but
that full spectrum does exist in
children and to okay have time for
another one for you as we know more
about human the human microbiome the
definition of proper personal hygiene
seems to be no longer and elimination of
all bacteria to stay healthy what are
the best practices to teach our children
on proper personal hygiene diversified
microbiome in mind this is a great
question thank you so clearly we are
learning that not all bacteria are bad
and then we probably don't need to
eliminate all bacteria from our lives as
as the war on bacteria and antibiotics
annada back antimicrobials might have
led us to believe um you know and why
don't we teach our children in terms of
purse or proper personal hygiene um you
know I think there's still well why I
think it's important to teach children
that we don't necessarily need to
eliminate all bacteria from our lives so
there are beneficial ones that things
like proper hand hygiene are still very
important proper food handling
techniques are still very important
because because we still we do
appreciate that although we want to keep
the good ones around we still need to be
very careful about the pathogens and
foodborne illness and things along those
lines so I think this is something
that's going to continue to evolve we
may reach a point where you know dousing
our kids and hand sanitizer is not the
accepted norm anymore but at the same
time using the soap and water and maybe
limiting antibiotics to ask cases where
they're absolutely necessary utilizing
more traditional say traditional
approaches rather than having triclosan
or antimicrobials and every personal
care product we use that we tend to
stick to sort of the basics or the soap
and water and
and lessons shall we say advanced
personal care products so I think this
is a great space to keep an eye on as as
we continue to learn more about our own
human microbiome and the ways we affect
our microbiome the way our built
environment affects us the way we
interact with it so I think that as I
said in terms of best practices for our
children we still need to teach them
about proper avoidance of pathogens but
at the same time that important
nutrition Whole Foods probiotic type
bacteria eating foods that could benefit
our bodies is still an important thing
to do
hope you have time for another one why
is it said that our normal skin flora
are opportunistic bacteria and I see
that we've had one additional question
dude if we have time like if we don't
have time let me know and this last
question or this this last question that
comes that's come in and said is says or
asks lies it said that our normal skin
for opportunistic bacteria um well um
Albert it mean opportunistic bacteria
may not quite be the appropriate word we
want to use but certainly skin flora do
contain a number of opportunistic
pathogens you can think of an
opportunistic pathogen is something akin
to a weed a plant so weed is a plant
that exists a place where it's not
appreciated and opportunistic pathogen
is also stanchions along the same lines
where its present in one person one
particular location it can be relatively
harmless and part of the normal
background but when introduced to say a
wound or to an income immunocompromised
individual can cause problems and so
there are special bacteria that do kind
of have that dual role of being
generally harmless in those situations
but when given the opportunity to take
advantage of a situation can be
considered opportunistic pathogens
I would like to once again thank dr.
Hollister for her presentation give any
final comments dr. Hollister that you'd
like to share and well I'd like to thank
everyone who attended today for your
time and attention I'd also like to
thank the organizers and sponsors for
this opportunity to share some
information and to share what we've been
learning about the pediatric microbiome
this is as I said I think this is a
really filled richland opportunity and I
think we'll be seeing a lot more out of
the sealed in the coming years so
definitely please keep an eye on this
space and thanks thanks everyone for
your time thank you dr. Hollister I
would also like to thank our sponsor
roche diagnostics for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2016
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting and knowing this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon bye